Making a movie is a collaborative effort,
but at the end of the day, the director is
the one who's calling the shots, and sometimes
they get things very wrong.
In fact, some of the greatest filmmakers in
history cringe when they remember certain
moments from their own movies.
Here's a look at some scenes that directors
regret shooting at all.
Cameron rewrites history
Titanic is one of the most popular films in
movie history, but not everyone is a fan thanks
to some artistic liberties taken by writer-director
James Cameron regarding the story of the ship's
first officer, William McMaster Murdoch.
A real historical figure who lost his life
in the tragic sinking of the Titanic, some
theorize that Murdoch may have committed suicide.
Though there's no proof at all, Cameron decided
to run with it, even adding a bit where Murdoch
shoots another character first.
Cameron explained to National Geographic
"I took the liberty of showing [Murdoch] shoot
somebody and then shoot himself [...] We don't
know he did that, but you know, the storyteller
in me says, 'Oh.'
I start connecting the dots.
He was on duty, he's carrying all this burden
with him, made him an interesting character."
Residents of Murdoch's hometown protested
the scene, and Murdoch's nephew worried the
film would ruin his ancestor's name.
Cameron ended up apologizing, saying,
"I wasn't thinking about being a historian,
and I think I wasn't as sensitive about the
fact that his family, his survivors, might
feel offended by that, and they were."
Coogler's tragic odyssey
You'd think that when it comes to Black Panther,
Ryan Coogler wouldn't have any regrets.
It's the most critically acclaimed film in
the MCU, it's the ninth highest-grossing film
of all time, and it was genuinely a landmark
moment in the history of superhero movies.
Still, Coogler told The Toronto Sun he regrets
getting rid of the villainous Ulysses Klaue,
played with verve by Andy Serkis.
"I like Klaue.
I was bugged by having to do that.
It's tough when you have to kill characters
off, and I really did love that character.
I love Andy.
He's a lovely person.
But again, it's one of those things where
when you've got so many people in a movie,
some of them have to go."
Abrams needs a hug
After the shocking death of Han Solo in Star
Wars: The Force Awakens, fans were in desperate
need of a hug.
And so, presumably, was Han's life partner,
Chewbacca.
Yet when he arrived back at the Rebel Base,
General Leia just walked right by him to offer
solace to Rey, a total stranger.
It's a scene that bugged a lot of people,
including director J.J. Abrams, who said he
regrets the optics of the situation.
He told Slashfilm it looks a lot worse than
it was, as Chewie was preoccupied with getting
the injured Finn some medical attention anyway.
"Had Chewbacca not been where he was, you
probably wouldn't have thought of it.
But because he was right there, passed by
Leia, it felt almost like a slight, which
was definitely not the intention."
Gluck insults Xenu
Tom Cruise may be the face of Scientology,
but Hollywood is filled with plenty of other
adherents, including actress Jenna Elfman.
Unfortunately, while attending the first screening
of her 2011 film Friends with Benefits, Elfman
was blindsided by a Scientology joke which
hadn't appeared in the script, and nobody
had warned her about it.
“And if any of these cameras are hooked
up to the actual Scientology center, that
was an inappropriate joke and I apologize.
I believe in the freedom of science fiction.”
Director Will Gluck told IndieWire he regretted
how the joke played out.
"The way I work, I change the script a lot.
While we're shooting, I'll yell out, 'Try
this, try that!'
We shot [the joke] once and then we left it
in.
But I feel really bad because I didn't tell
Jenna about it, and then I forgot."
Whoops!
Gluck triggers a reaction
After the Scientology fiasco, you'd think
director Will Gluck would have learned his
lesson.
But in the 2018 film Peter Rabbit, Gluck incited
an uproar thanks to a scene where the supposedly
cute rabbits intentionally trigger a nearly
fatal allergic reaction in Domhnall Gleeson's
character by attacking him with blackberries.
The scene led to major backlash online, and
Asthma and Allergy Foundation of America even
weighed in, condemning the sequence for making
light of such a serious issue in a children's
film.
As a result, Gluck and Sony Picture formally
apologized, saying that they were... berry,
berry sorry.